Маартен Хеммен страждає на маніакально-депресивний психоз.
Він - один з близько 350 мільйонів людей у світі, які потерпають від цього захворювання.
Сьогодні вранці мені було зле.
Коли я прокинувся, почувався, як у тумані -
таке в мене часто.
Постійна зміна депресивних та маніакальних фаз -
надзвичайно важкий виклик у повсякденному житті молодого чоловіка родом з Нідерландів.
Зовні Маартен зовсім не справляє враження депресивної людини.
Насправді ж найбанальніші речі в житті нерідко перетворюються для нього
на справжнісіньку проблему.
Наприклад, підйом вранці чи інші побутові справи.
Впоратися з ними Маартену допомагають певні ритуали,
медитація, а ще відвертість з іншими, коли йдеться про його стан.
Гадаю, я добре навчився доносити до людей довкола себе,
хто я і як я на що реагую, і це допомагає.
Іноді я багатьох друзів попереджаю: мовляв, будьте зі мною сьогодні обачнішими - мені й так зле.
Безнадія, внутрішня порожнеча та відчуття провини охоплюють Маартена під час депресивних фаз.
Шість років тому ці почуття взяли гору - Маартен намагався звести рахунки з життям.
Натомість під час маніакальних фаз чоловік  - особливо креативний, натхненний і працьовитий.
Ці контрасти Маартен відображає у своїй музиці.
Завдяки психотерапії та лікам Маартен більше не схильний до суїциду.
Чіткий розпорядок дня, спорт і медитація допомагають контролювати захворювання.
І навіть якщо ці методи допомагають далеко не всім хворим,
Маартен прагне поділитися своїм досвідом з іншими.
Розповісти про себе музиканта запросили на дискусійний захід у Кельні, де він мешкає.
Я  дуже хвилююся.
Хотілося б, щоб люди дійсно зрозуміли, що у мені відбувається і що я хочу донести.
А ще хочеться надихнути людей вдатися до тих же кроків у житті, які зробив я.
Спорт - для Маартена чи не найважливіший інструмент у боротьбі з депресією.
Йдеться не лише про досягнення рівноваги між тілом та психікою,
а й про можливість довести собі, що він на щось здатний.
Я знаю людей без ніг, які займаються скелелазінням.
Тут є одна жінка, яка піднімається попри відсутність ніг.
Гадаю, людина сама визначає, наскільки вона обмежена.
І це одна зі складових депресії: сказати, що я цього не можу. Але чого саме ти не можеш?
Бувають дні, коли мені здається, що я не можу встати з ліжка, але ж я можу встати.
У мене є руки й ноги.
Аби підтримати Маартена перед промовою, в гості до нього завітала Верена Гайнц.
Колишній дівчині музиканта не раз довелося переживати з ним найгірші депресії.
Гадаю, найважчим для мене у стосунках з Маартеном було те, що його
емоційні зриви були непередбачуваними.
Постійні злети і падіння, то на коні, то на дні - настрій мінявся дуже швидко.
Я раптом помічала: ось він такий, а тоді відразу ж інакший.
Напевне, це було для мене найбільшим викликом.
Заручитися підтримкою Маартен їздить також до батьків у Нідерланди.
Шість років тому, посеред відпустки,
вони отримали дзвінок від сина, який сказав, що більше не хоче жити.
Ми почувалися безсилими і сумними.
Нам було дуже важко зрозуміти це, адже Маартен має і почуття гумору, і життєрадісність.
Як батькам нам було важко, ми відчували себе винними.
Відразу починаєш думати: що ми зробили не так?
Чому ми цього не помітили?
З таким важко змиритися.
Наступного дня після дзвінка батькам Маартен випив смертельну суміш
зі снодійних та знеболюючих ліків.
У ту мить мені було дійсно байдуже.
Мені просто хотілося позбутися цього відчуття, не мусити жити з цим болем.
Зрештою щось мене таки привело до тями, переконало: не роби цього!
Що б не трапилося на світі, це не може бути вирішенням проблеми.
Тоді я пішов у туалет, вирвав.
З тієї миті я мислив доволі ясно і викликав швидку.
Нині Маартен вже навчився краще справлятися зі своїми злетами і падіннями.
Певні ритуали на кшталт крижаної купелі допомагають у цьому.
З невдач він черпає нові сили.
Про це він також хоче розповісти під час виступу.
І ось цей день настав.
Разом з другом та менеджером Максом Маартен прибуває на місце заходу.
Під час проб та останніх приготувань хвилювання ще більше зростає.
Час виходити на сцену.
Мене звати Маартен Хеммен і я страждаю на важкі депресії. Знову й знову я починаю стримувати себе.
Свої запитання, емоції.
Ховати все те, що мене визначає.
Напевне, найкраще просто функціонувати. Я почав шукати стимули для балансу.
Крута ідея! Чудова ідея!
Алкоголь, наркотики, водити авто із заплющеними очима - дедалі довше.
Псувати своє здоров'я, небезпечний секс, бійки, саморуйнування.
Коли шість років тому моя депресія стала такою, що я вже не знав, як бути далі,
я намагався накласти на себе руки.
Чому я не говорив?
Причина, чому я мовчав, дуже проста.
Про психічні проблеми не говорять.
Цього мене навчили доволі рано.
У школі, у гуртку, вдома чи у друзів.
Проте тепер я говорю, я говорю без упину. Німеччино, нам треба поговорити!
Перші реакції після виступу не примушують на себе чекати.
Багато людей у захваті очікують Маартена у фойє.
Той факт, що хтось може так відкрито розповідати про своє захворювання,
дарує нову надію багатьом тим, хто страждає на маніакально-депресивний психоз.
Надію, що їм вдасться знайти шлях опанувати свої депресії, як це зумів Маартен.